und jetzt ein anderes Thema es ist der
21 November eine Familie ist gerade auf
dem Nachhauseweg und gerät in eine
Polizeikontrolle und dann fließt
plötzlich Blut am Ende liegt einer von
zwei Brüdern mit einem Nasen und
Jochbeinbruch in der Klinik die Polizei
äußert sich zu dem Vorfall bisher nur
spärlich was bleibt ist also die Frage
wie konnte es dazu kommen
es beginnt mit einer Polizeikontrolle
die Polizistin erklärt bei uns ging ein
Notruf ein dass das Personen bisschen
rumfliegen vorne vom Stadthotel die
Familie filmt das Geschehen die beiden
Brüder Dennis und Samuel Fragen immer
wieder warum sie kontrolliert werden
einer der Brüder Samuel soll sich vor
der Polizei ausweisen trotz mehrfacher
Aufforderung und Warnung vor
Konsequenzen weiß sich Samuel nicht aus
als er den Ausweis immer noch nicht
zeigt schlägt ihm der Beamte die Füße
weg Samuel landet auf dem Asphalt die
Mutter räumt ein Dennis wollte seinen
Bruder helfen er zog den Polizisten an
der Schulter dann eskaliert die
Situation
irgendwann liegt Dennis blutend am Boden
er kommt mit einem Nasen und
Jochbeinbruch in die Klinik die Familie
erstattet Anzeige wegen Verdachts der
Körperverletzung im Amt die Polizei
äußert sich gegenüber Bild nur
schriftlich im Zusammenhang mit einer
Kontrolle soll es zu Widerstandshandlung
und einem täglichen Angriff auf
Polizeibeamte und in der Folge Anwendung
von unmittelbarem Zwang über diesen Fall
zu sprechen ist jetzt BILD-Reporter
Matthias Becker ja Matthias bisher
schweigt die Polizei beziehungsweise
äußert sich nur spärlich zu dem Vorfall
wieso eigentlich
die Polizei steckt da in einem Dilemma
sie möchte schon ganz gerne aufklären
aber sie ist hier in diesem Fall selbst
betroffen sie ist selbst angezeigt
worden und da kann die Polizei leider
nicht so öffentlich drüber reden wie sie
es gleich vielleicht gerne machen möchte
der Staatsanwalt hat gesagt nein ich bin
Herdes Verfahrens und wir sagen erst
einmal nichts um die objektiven
Ermittlungen auch nicht zu gefährden die
Polizei du sagst möchte darüber
öffentlich gar nicht so sehr sprechen
dann tun wir das an dieser Stelle du als
ehemaliger Polizist kennst auch das
Videomaterial schauen wir noch mal
gemeinsam drauf du kennst die Szenen du
hast sie gesehen wie schätzt du das ein
was wir hier sehen bzw diesen Vorfall
gehen wir einmal noch mal durch hier
eben sieht es noch alles relativ harmlos
aus da ist es einfach nur eine
Polizeikontrolle aber wie gesagt einer
der Brüder der möchte sich eben nicht
ausweisen und dann kommt es zu dieser zu
dieser Prügelei
ja aber das ist ganz einfach also die
Polizei kommt ja nicht von ungefähr nur
einfach nur mal daher sondern sie hat
ein Notruf bekommen es gibt eine
Ruhestörung vielleicht auch eine
Beleidigung und sie entschließt sich in
die Beamten hat das ganz ruhig und
deutlich aber eindringlich den Personen
auch erklärt das ist eine allgemeine
Identitätsüberprüfung nach dem asog
allgemeines sicherheits- und
ordnungsgesetz und sie möchte eine
Identitätsfeststellung vornehmen und die
kann sie auch tun das ist jetzt hier
eine Freiheitsbeschränkung ich behalte
die Personen vor Ort sie können jetzt
nicht ihren Weg fortsetzen sondern sie
müssen das einfach über sich erdulden
lassen das ist so
wie kommt es dann zu dieser Eskalation
mehr es ist auch ganz einfach die
Polizei kann ja nicht sagen ach du
möchtest Dich nicht durch
feststellen lassen wie du heißt und wo
du wohnst dann kann er die Polizei nicht
einfach wieder gehen sondern sie muss
jetzt die getroffene Maßnahme die
identitätsverstellung und auch
durchsetzen ich habe keine
Mitwirkungspflicht ich muss also nichts
aktiv tun aber wenn die Polizei und das
geht auch bis hin zur Durchsuchung von
der Jacken zum Auffinden von Beweisen
ausweisen oder auch Führerschein die die
Identität deiner Person irgendwie
feststellen lassen das geht sogar so
weit dass ich die Person rein
theoretisch auch mit in den Abschnitt
zum Abschnitt zum Revier nehmen kann
wenn sich dort die Identität nur dort
feststellen lassen kann jetzt ist es
auch so der Festgenommene der ist
tatsächlich polizeibekannt ist es
vielleicht auch möglich jetzt wie gesagt
rein denkbar dass die Polizei diesen
Menschen sowieso schon auf dem Schirm
hatte und dass man da vielleicht auch
einfach mal ein bisschen ja mit mehr
Nachdruck dem ganzen nachgeht
nein das ist unerheblich also wir
sprechen hier einfach von einer
identitätsverstellung die hat ja nicht
über sich ergehen lassen wollen dann hat
ja Polizist standardmäßig mit einem wir
nennen das fußfähiger die Person zu
Boden gebracht um ihn zu durchsuchen und
jetzt passiert folgendes jetzt kommt
sein Bruder und packt den Polizisten von
hinten rein und jetzt reden wir von
nicht von einer identitätsverstellung
sondern jetzt reden wir von einer
Straftat weil das ist schon ein
Widerstand der könnte sogar bis in den
Bereich einer versuchten
Gefangenenbefreiung gehen und dann hat
er leider da schlechte Karten und
genauso das sehen wir hier auch das wird
dann durchgesetzt also von Polizei Seite
her uns zusammenzufassen nach deiner
Einschätzung alles korrekt
ja wenn ich eins noch sagen darf die
Eltern sehr entsetzt natürlich auch das
was mit ihrem Sohn geschehen ist aber
meine Frage ist natürlich warum haben
die Eltern nicht gleich beschwichten
eingegriffen oder haben beruhigend auf
die Söhne eingesprochen dass doch
einfach geschehen zu lassen wir sehen es
doch jeden Tag dass der
polizeibeamtenuniform als Vertreter der
Staates von Respektlosigkeit bis hin zu
massiven Angriffen ausgesetzt ist warum
mache ich das nicht ich kann jedem
Maßnahme jede polizeiliche Maßnahme kann
ich überprüfen lassen warum macht man
das nicht
Einschätzung von immerzwecker unserem
Polizeiexperten vielen Dank dafür